this is what this has happened to me one
time I was at the airport and it has
like you know they have different lines
yeah okay so they had this like TSA pre
line yeah okay I'm in the TSA pre line
now it's getting kind of long everybody
has TSA pre now so she didn't even
special but there's you two old people
and I saw the tickets I new date and
they were trying to cut and I'm looking
around everybody's got an adage
everybody's like huh and I say I go okay
I'm gonna be the only one you go put
this all on me yeah yeah yeah I had to
go excuse me you in the wrong place you
need to move on you know it's like I
hate that's why cuz people don't want to
you know what you put your anything at
that TSA a pocket [ __ ] wait why do you
know why why is that cuz they don't know
what it is through the scanner so it
always gets opened up okay and then they
had to [ __ ] pull it out okay because
it's mine
it's sticky because of me alright but he
has to pick it up now my question is you
should make a mold of your dick and you
should make we have a possible pocket
[ __ ] are you guys so rare well we have
Bobby's dick you have so many like stuff
you guys should one sent us a dick maker
dildo maker that's why you can make ten
of Bobby's
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll be cool I'll be cool I take it back
yeah Bobby this is as big as you I mean
imagine yeah yeah it's light skin tone
too yeah yeah we have to dip this in
mustard on the stage the other day
what'd you say that look like my Bobby
looks like you know the honey bottle
yeah with a bear honey Bob yeah yeah but
it's filled with master
he said that in front of a crowd today I
said Bobby looks like if some Asian kids
peed in the snow then they made a
snowman out of that don't try to on
camera right now
oh wow this is what he does this is it
so I believe you the worst I say that
you don't look human
you look like Tim Burton drew you the
other episode we've had on tiger belly
he says something about my gosh about
the billboard in Times Square yeah I was
leaning yeah but your billboard would be
on a hotdog stand because we have a
question yeah oh yeah